hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today I am sick
I'm also an idiot but I'll get to that
in a second so today on my sick day I
thought that I would take a little bit
of a break and not really do anything
but I noticed that my sinuses were a
little stuffed up I thought to myself
well what's the best way to get rid of a
stuffed-up sinus and I thought oh I know
this five million Scoville hot sauce
that I got that'll do the trick right up
but then I thought to myself huh it sure
would be a shame to not record this and
put this on the internet for everyone to
see how big of a doof I am so then
that's what I didn't here we are and
that's what you're seeing right now
great huh cool so if you know me I don't
do anything half-ass which is funny
because after this I'm gonna have only
half an ass left I kick [ __ ] up to
eleven thousand or five million because
that's how many scovilles this is if you
don't know what a Scoville is it means
hot it's 5 million hots that's what it
means
also I paid $80 for this also comes in a
coffin which is also funny because when
I'm done with this all my ashes that are
gonna be left will fit inside this and
then I'll be buried in it and everyone
will be sad but not me I'll be dead
great so this stuff is called meet your
maker which is funny also because it's
made by a company called heavenly heat
gourmet hot sauce which is weird cuz I
know this is concentrated from 10,000
demon buttholes and it's only gonna be a
one-way ticket straight to hell great ok
also I decided to play a game that I
hate I am bread which as you know is my
favorite game except for the fact that I
hate it also I have milk here for
emergency but I'm never gonna reach it
cuz all the way on that end of the desk
about the time my hand which will be on
fire after I drink this reaches it it'll
all melt I'll be dead it's caiaphas eyes
I'm gonna die basically pretty much cool
all right so this thing comes in double
wax seal probably to prevent idiots from
trying to get into it but I'm no idiot
or so I either way I probably can open
this so here we go I don't think they
want me to get into this pretty sealed
up I got a tight seal on this I think I
need a knife Barbie ok I'm back with a
safety knife because remember when
you're about to die from overdose of hot
sauce safety first how cool is this not
the dying part and then how cool is the
knife
it's got a little wolf okay okay that
only took 15 [ __ ] minutes but now
we're finally ready take a whiff of you
ha smells great everybody oh man it
looks great - all aboard the dumb train
choo-choo this is actually dangerous
this is borderline insanity what I'm
doing if I were to take an ice cream
scoop full of this I would probably have
to go to the hospital so I'm not gonna
be stupid I'm a professional idiot let
me handle this
I'm doing this to clear my sinuses I'm
not a doctor as you can see it's already
melting the fork off of the fork and as
such as melting the fork so enough
pussyfooting around here we go Yolo or
something hmm how's that bad I said that
bad oh it's not that bad huh oh it's not
that bad huh I carry that [ __ ] already
always go - oh it's not that bad
how about that Batman Oh ha why do I
still feel tasted huh oh this kids
picture the kitten is not helping this
is you aw Oh hmm
okay I'm gonna remember the I bread
controls because it's been a while
also I hate it I bet I hate it that
misses terribly stupid decision from a
guy who is sick day Wow I'm swear you
already oh I have no words at the moment
but hey I made it out of the window
sills alone pretty good
wow oh wow oh wow
good thing I had milk right actually
because holy [ __ ] oh my god why did I do
this breathing it hurts
ah
Oh Oh the important thing is not to
worry about things I go to my happy
place through with Ken's and penguins
and [ __ ] oh my god my holding else is
knowing them oh oh I don't know if it
worth I go here this right yeah oh yeah
I feel oh oh I can't even yell the bed
baby
huh I know what all your screaming doh
doh doh
no why did you do that would you [ __ ]
late now maybe my saliva has turned into
lava I'm crying profusely have they lost
i by taste bud can you even say a single
word
hey right now everything is what you
guys thought that was a to bite BIOS
wrong toenails and this guy's younger
love it I think I'm in the euphoric
moment and remembering my childhood and
remember as a baby
bah bah bah was said to be don't put
five Billy's Covell hot sauce into you
you dumbass what the [ __ ] are you doing
all the weight I think that's a virgin
from the future after this my mom's
going all me up and tell me what a
[ __ ] idiot I am
oh pretty kitty
does I break a blade I am bread oh don't
even care about anything anymore I just
what world peace
how are the hungry eat what'd I miss
everything tingles
I feel a tingling in my soul I thought
they're clearing up is working guy and
working boy just want to go home be my
bobby lee should what Bobby I just watch
my Bobby
Oh five million oh hi million every six
million subscribers
okay so that bad another bad Oh bad Oh
bad so we're gonna think there's a goat
dying in here oh no my lifts have gone
down oh I think the bouncing helps this
is not manly man I'm a Sikh little boy
oh okay I can't even see what's going on
screaming flailing buttons randomly oh
wow my face is leaking every fluid known
to humankind
I think of creating new elements of
matter in my mouth ah I think I'm
reaching temperatures hotter than the
surface of the Sun inside my stomach oh
oh this is a transcendental moment
transcendental orchestra oh yeah you're
close to Christmas oh oh I try hold back
we give that goddamn milk the way so bad
I wasn't milk in my mouth so badly oh
[ __ ] okay do I do we owe this quest look
Nick what Bali crusher was you described
Oh your home country by the old Russia
oh you beat us are gonna [ __ ] kill ya
piece of [ __ ] oh god damn barbed wire
[ __ ] are ya
knock your peace [ __ ] kitty [ __ ] cat
eye and your [ __ ] guy huh hey Jess are
you [ __ ] you right I feel like I've
waited I got it forgot out of the bucket
[ __ ] bounce control the work I can
[ __ ] do it
oh I can [ __ ] do it look at you huh I
guess heaven in hell are raging a battle
inside of my mouth but wait I remember
my technique from the previous time I
did good
ah [ __ ] holy [ __ ] it chug huh oh
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ]
hey was it worth it who's gonna Jam huh
ah okay ah ha I can't [ __ ] it I can't do
it okay
well back Oh
kicking the arms of the angel here Sylar
every I'm in the uncle
they're giving me [ __ ] milk thank you
okay okay well I was a fruitless venture
because my sinuses are still frickin
stuffed up I took like it I took like a
30-minute break in between before and
after I even took a selfie for Twitter
once I started to feel it better right
oh I'm gonna pay for this probably later
tonight how okay with that oh and I mean
the I'm in the euphoric stage like after
you take something that's very very hot
because sometimes enter the state of
euphoria where everything seems to be
okay excuse my appearance um but thank
you all so much for watching thank you
for shouting and screaming at the screen
no no no please mark dear god no why are
you doing this No
in that exact order so I did it anyway
so here I am still alive will chip hop
that tomorrow but I feel really good
right now just because of what I went
through when you get into pain sometimes
the brain kicks back that's all there is
so thank you all so much for watching if
you enjoyed my suffering like let me
know the comments below if you thought I
was a horrible person for doing this let
me know in the comments below but hey I
suffered through all that for you guys
mostly for me for you guys too so if you
enjoyed this video please leave a like
down below especially for my suffering
and how much I went through come on guys
please just for me I know you didn't
like it some of you but a lot of you
probably got a big laugh out of it maybe
alright so thank you get everybody for
watching remember there's a charity
livestream tomorrow I'm gonna be doing
and hopefully I won't be nearly as sick
to the point where I think that chugging
5 million Gobel hot sauce is a good idea
so thanks again everybody check out my
other impossible Let's Plays on the
first time I did hot sauce over in the
annotation or the description
thanks again guys and as always I will
see you in the next bye bye shut up
everybody this is deadly holy crap